shortly after an 18-year-old opened fire
on children at an elementary school in
Uvaldi Texas last year killing 19
students and two teachers the New York
Times published a lengthy front page
article on the Killer's background and
one line in the Times report didn't last
very long before an editor deleted it
from the article without explanation the
sentence in question quoted one of the
gunman's co-workers at Wendy's as saying
that quote he would often talk about how
much he despised his mother and
grandmother whom he told her did not let
him smoke weed or do what he wanted it
was never clear why that particular line
was deleted most likely they wanted to
push gun confiscation instead and it
kind of confused The
Narrative but in any event the New York
Times didn't want to talk about the
shooters marijuana use if the Blogger
Alex baronson hadn't spotted the change
uh it's likely no one would have ever
noticed it what we do know is that if
the shooter yaldi was indeed a pothead
then there are a lot of other examples
just like it many other Mass shooters
from Parkland to Aurora to Tucson to
Southerland Springs were reported
marijuana users that dovet tales with
research showing that young people who
use marijuana were more than twice as
likely to commit acts of violence just
give one example the American Journal of
Psychiatry published a metaanalysis of
several large-scale studies three years
ago the conclusion was this quote these
results demonstrate a moderate
association between cannabis use and
physical violence cannabis use in this
population is a risk factor for
violence now you never hear about these
studies probably for the same reason
that the New York Times censored itself
for mentioning marijuana in the context
of the Uvaldi shooting in Elite circles
talking about the consequences of
marijuana use is unpopular anything that
discourages people from smoking more
weed is also disfavored it's almost like
they want the masses to be drugged and
passive which might explain why the
cigar tax in New York is 75% while the
marijuana tax is less than
15% regardless of what exactly explains
that discrepancy the PR effort to push
marijuana has obviously been successful
over the past decade two dozen states
have passed some form of legalization or
decriminalization of marijuana and
because slippery slopes are real and
anybody who uses the term slippery slope
fallacy is lying to you the
decriminalization movement did not end
there instead it progressed far beyond
marijuana as it was always destined to
do three years ago on the heels of the
race riots following the overdose of
George Floyd
Oregon became the first state in the
country to decriminalize the possession
of all illegal drugs not just marijuana
but every illegal drug nearly 60% of
Voters in the state approved this
measure is measure 110 uh along with a
separate measure that legalized the use
of hallucinogenic mushrooms for therapy
and the idea was that the laws against
heroin and meth and Other Drugs were
counterproductive and oppressive and of
course racist so they had to go and
hopes were high as Vox reported at the
time quote given that decriminalization
is so far untried in the US it's
difficult to say how it would play out
in that sense measure 110 would create a
realtime experiment for Oregon and the
rest of the
country well not long afterwards though
um we started to see the results of this
experiment problems began to emerge we
might say in 2022 a local news station
embedded with the head of a Portland
drug interdiction task force and here's
what they learned watch back at the
office bergus is willing to show us
drugs and guns seized recently in two
separate cases those little blue pills
are fentanyl and it's everywhere it's
everybody we contact uh I have a couple
of cases that are back-to-back cases we
did this week and in each case it's uh
fental possession and stolen handguns
and this is almost everything we do
right now how much does measure 110 have
to do with it uh measure 110 has
everything to do with it Ferguson said
because measure 110 reduced possession
for small amounts of of drugs including
oxycodone the drug business has
flourished the fenel pills are uh
counterfeit oxycotton pills and by
decriminalizing that it's basically
legitimized criminal organizations and
the drug possession use and sale is just
rampant with very little consequences
and it's taking away our tools as police
officers to sort of interdict that
reported drug offenses in Portland
dropped from 880 the year before measure
110 went into effect to 3 64 the year
after police still do have some tools
and Ferguson was involved in a bust last
June in which investigators found 500
fenel pills along with 44 Firearms two
of which were machine guns and 1,000 G
of
methamphetamine okay so measure 110 the
officer says is the reason that Fentanyl
and stolen handguns and machine guns are
flooding organ measure 110 has
everything to do with it he tells the
reporter well now 3 years after measure
110 was passed a voter ERS are tired of
it it only took 3 years polls now show
that a majority of residents in Oregon
want to re criminalize hard drugs after
they just decriminalized it now they
want to rec criminalize it and a ballot
measure doing so is expected next year
that's because predictably
decriminalizing cocaine and heroin and
everything else has led to nothing less
than a breakdown of society in Oregon to
the extent that there was a society
there before this this week the Wall
Street Journal published an extensive
analysis into the effect of measure 110
on the state it's a report that
everybody should read as it just I mean
it entirely annihilates the case for
drug Le legalization I don't think
there's ever been a side of an issue
that has been this thoroughly and
completely debunked using not just
studies or speculation but real world
now we see in the real world what
actually happens when all drugs are
legalized and it is a disaster and yet
still almost all the pro drug legalizers
are simply ignoring it they've gotten
what they wanted in Oregon and to a
lesser extent all across the country but
you notice that they're not out like
touting the success of the policy they
advocated for maybe you notice that and
that's because there is no success it
has been a
catastrophy you know if you own a
firearm then you need to check out
stopbox USA they just introduced the
stopbox pro this new safe is the most
reliable secure safe uh to put your
firearm in the stopbox Pro is larger
stronger more versatile crafted from
durable glass reinforced polycarbonate
ABS it's not just tough it's smart you
don't need to be fumbling with keys or
electronic codes and high stress
situations the stopbox proos patented
hand gesture code lock allows quick
intuitive access without batteries or
Electronics they understand the critical
balance between security and
accessibility that's why the stopbox pro
is designed to be lowprofile and
portable whether at home or traveling
your firearm remains concealed secure
yet also readily accessible stopbox pro
has an expanded range of 81 combination
possibilities making it more
customizable than ever plus an enhanced
surface texture for a better grip and
the improved locking mechanism is a
breeze top rate don't compromise on
safety and accessibility visit stopbox
usa.com use promo code Matt for 10% off
your order experience the peace of mind
that the stopbox can bring that's
stopbox usa.com and use promo code Matt
for 10% off your order just in time for
the holidays genu cell is offering their
best sale of the year right now you get
70% % off genu cell's most popular
package which now includes genu cell 3
their newest under eye treatment genu
cell 3 will have you looking 10 15 even
20 years younger it uses advanced
technology to deliver complex vitamins
and minerals directly to your face for
instant hydration say goodbye to Fine
Lines crows feet under eye bags and dark
spots the genl experience is like no
other but don't just take my word for
genl will have you looking and feeling
your absolute best guaranteed or your
money back no questions asked you
deserve to look and feel your best this
holiday season so go to jus cell.com /
Walsh YT to get the this incredible
holiday discount for 70% off their most
popular package which includes the genu
cell 3 and the Dark Spot Corrector get
results in 12 hours or less the
immediate effects are included for free
j.com Walt for 70% off plus free
priority shipping that's genucell.com
walshy today the paper reports that as a
result of the law quote people sprawled
on sidewalks and using fentanyl with no
fear of consequence have become a common
in cities such as Eugene and Portland
from May of 2022 to May of this year the
number of fatal overdoses in the state
increased by more than 20% to, 1500
overdoses that is the third highest jump
in the entire country police in Eugene
Oregon uh report that this year there
have been 858 calls for overdoses in
2020 the number was 438 which was
already high and now it's like
double the whole point of measure 110
was to force these people to go to
rehabilitation services instead of jail
but of course that hasn't worked either
quote some 6,000 tickets have been
issued for drug possessions since
decriminalization went into effect in
2021 but just 92 people have called and
completed assessments needed to connect
them to Services according to the
journal the only penalty for those who
don't call is a $100 fine which is
rarely
enforced so in some Oregon's decision to
decriminalize all drugs has been an
abject and totally predictive
disaster it turns out that when you
invite people to do drugs whenever and
wherever they want you end up with a lot
more people doing drugs whenever and
wherever they
want you know advocates for
decriminalization have always claimed
that somehow decriminalizing drug use
will not lead to more drug use as though
the law has no effect on people's
behavior but that flies in the face of
everything we've observed about human
behavior since the dawn of civilized
society
okay so put it simply laws matter when
the law allows a certain Behavior you
get more of that behavior like it's not
hard to figure out this equation it's
actually very simple and that's why
unless we want a lot more overdose
deaths and illegal guns in major cities
we should be taking a very close look at
all forms of drug decriminalization
including the more limited and uh uh you
know efforts that we've seen across the
country as I mentioned earlier weed is
legal in most places now how is that
working out is there any evidence that
it's making anything better can we look
at like the promises that were made by
the the the weed legalization uh
side look at their promises like has any
of that panned
out I mean by the naked eye it certainly
seems to uh rather rather than helping
anything it seems to be contributing to
our social Decay it has a demoralizing
effect at the very least to walk through
any city in America now and smell the
stench of weed everywhere with people
walking around stoned anywhere you
go and I say this by the way as someone
who for a Time believed that that weed
not any other drug should probably be
you know just be legalized or at least
decriminalized as much as I personally
don't like the
drug there was a time when I bought into
that same idea but I can look around at
our cities and smell the stench
everywhere and see people high on drugs
everywhere and I can ask myself has this
made society better or has it made it
worse I mean that's the question
everyone should be asking
themselves now aside from the naked eye
test what does the data say for a lot of
reasons it's hard to measure the precise
impact of marijuana decriminalization on
people's quality of life there are so
many variables including the decision by
leftist Das to stop enforcing a bunch of
other laws and because of that you know
it's difficult to ascribe any particular
blame to one specific policy or another
it's all kind of like a a jumbled mess
now to be sure a lot of jurisdictions
that have legalized or decriminalized
marijuana have seen significant
increases in crime New York legalized
cannabis in 2021 for example and then
immediately saw its overall crime index
Jump by more than
22% along the same lines after
Washington's Supreme Court struck down
the state's drug laws effectively
effectively legalizing um all drugs
until legislators could fix the problem
crime spiked Washington's rate of
violent crimes jumped from 33 7 per
100,000 people in 2021 to more than 375
per 100,000 people in the following year
now there's no easy way to determine
with absolute certainty at this stage
what role drug legalization is playing
in all of these numbers specifically
there have been some attempts at
drilling this down a couple of years ago
Analyst at the Justice research and
statistics Association looked at the
impact of marijuana legalization or
decriminalization in 11 States including
Washington Arizona California Colorado
Nebraska and others and they they did
this by speaking to local officials and
law enforcement personnel and hearing
what they had to say and the researchers
found that after Washington State
legalized recreational marijuana use in
2020 arrests for both The Possession and
distribution of heroin and
methamphetamine increased
significantly and remember we were
always told that the whole thing about
the gateway drug is a is a myth it's a
fallacy it's a myth
it's not what the numbers show meanwhile
in Colorado which also decriminalized
pot a decade ago the researchers found
that quote respondents in particular
reported an increase in the homeless
population from individuals moving to
the state for jobs in the marijuana
industry that failed to materialize
other concerns expressed by interviewees
related to criminal Behavior associated
with the marijuana business such as
attempts to steal marijuana and take
over uh selling from locals in Oregon
there were similar concerns quote an
Oregon respondent reported a 55 to 60%
increase in marijuana related DUIs
following marijuana decriminalization
along the same lines a separate research
team from the University of Utah
scrutinized crime data from Morgan and
they found that quote uh results provide
some evidence demonstrating a crime
exacerbating effect of recreational
marijuana legalization as reflected by
substantial increases in the rates of
multiple types of serious crime in
Oregon relative to non- legalized States
following legalization uh including
property and violent crime overall as
well as other crimes such as burglary
motor vehicle theft larsy and aggravated
assault now
none of this is really particularly
surprising given that marijuana is a
psychoactive drug that's been linked to
Violent Behavior what is perhaps
surprising though is that given what we
know and don't know several states are
still pushing the decriminalization
agenda Ohio for example is set to
decriminalize the drug in just a few
weeks and I want you to watch how local
news is covering this watch well
marijuana will be legal to buy and sell
in the Buckeye state in just 24 days but
that doesn't doesn't mean the marijuana
shops will be open just quite yet our
Michael sandin he joins us live from the
East side tonight and Michael I
understand you spoke to a professor who
kind of broke down the timeline until
people can actually buy
marijuana yeah jefff I spoke to
Professor Brandon Cohen who teaches
multiple can cannabis management classes
UT too he said looking at how things
went in Michigan and Colorado he expects
it'll be a little over a year before we
start seeing marijuana shops pop up in
our local neighborhoods he walked me
through the process it's going to take
to get there saying that once issue two
makes it through the legislature it's
passed off to the Department of Commerce
the same group that regulates and works
with legal medical marijuana and liquor
they s all the rules and regulations for
sale which will take at least a few
months once that's finished they'll ask
the public to submit proposals for
businesses and once those are reviewed
and the best candidates are selected for
licenses we you start seeing businesses
for recreational use start to pop up
around Q4 of next year now if you voted
for issue two you know on the ballot it
says these new businesses will bring in
hundreds of millions of dollars in Tex
and tax
revenue and the report goes on like that
for a few minutes longer where you
notice that they're not talking about
how decriminalizing marijuana is going
to make everybody more productive and
and happier members of society they're
not claiming that it's going to make the
state a better place to live which is
really what every law ultimately should
be designed to do every law ultimately
should have the objective of making uh
life better for people that before you
talk about rights and freedoms like that
ultimately is supposed to be the goal
and if there's a law that's going to
make life worse for people then then it
it then it's a bad law like that's the
number one way that you know it's a bad
law of it's making life worse it's
really not it's actually a pretty simple
test so they're not talking about
they're not they're not talking about
how safe the schools in Ohio will be
after young children with mental
disorders are granted even easier access
to psychoactive drugs instead they're
talking about tax revenue you know
they're telling you how much money the
state will make that's the whole pitch
they're not even pretending otherwise
and that tells you something that even
left-wing voters in Oregon are now
realizing which is that the more
recreational drugs you legalize the more
crime and Urban Decay you have to deal
with this really should not be a
surprise people people are again more
likely to do something when there is no
legal ramification for doing it that
doesn't mean everyone stops doing drugs
when you make it illegal it just means
that the fewer obstacles in the way the
fewer consequences the more of that
behavior you get and so before you
legalize drugs you should ask yourself
is it going to be good for society if
more people are doing this do we want
that is that is that a positive is that
something we want to do we want to
facilitate that as
voters and if you answer no to that
question then you Don't Legalize
It and it's not just because of the
Practical obstacles put in place when
something is illegal it's also because
the law is a teacher as the saying goes
a a thing begins to seem less
objectionable to people when the law
endorses
it that's the problem and also there's
something else that we've been that's
been revealed by the decriminalization
across the country especially in Oregon
so the other thing that that we hear
from the libertarian types is that well
if you you could decriminalize drugs and
it only it it it just affects the when
people someone decides to do drugs it
just affects them it just affects their
life let people do what they want to do
with their own lives if they want to
poison themselves doesn't affect anybody
else okay well it's very clear that that
is not the case see it turns out when
you've got um a bunch of people who are
all deciding to poison themselves it has
a it has a a an enormous impact on
everybody else the breakdown of society
actually affects
everybody so ultimately there's no
upside for anyone but the State Treasury
and also the politicians who desperately
need voters to be as stoned and
submissive and out of it as possible
otherwise if voters aren't High out of
their minds they might realize what
these politicians are doing to their
communities they might realize that
destruction and Decay are a choice and
then like the voters in Oregon they
might decide they've finally had enough
of
it hey YouTube thanks for listening to
the show if you'd like access to my full
show with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there